il est en tout cas que la stratégie
vaccinale ne convainc toujours pas elle
est critiquée pour son absence
d'anticipation pour ces lenteurs pour
son recours au cabinet privé mckinsey
alors il ya c'est olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé qui a tenté de la
défendre face aux parlementaires du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale
et aujourd'hui même et bien c'est le
premier ministre jean castex qui a dû
essuyer les foudres des sénateurs et
dans une ambiance vraiment houleuse
alors lui s'est défendu en expliquant
que cette stratégie était connue depuis
le départ de tous les parlementaires ici
présents qui s'en étonne aujourd'hui je
vous propose de l'écouter
la france n'a pas à rougir de sa
stratégie globale de lutte contre cette
pandémie
je ne vous demande pas de cesser de
critiquer et de contrôler le
gouvernement c'est votre robe
je demande simplement que nous nous auto
flageller ou pas
c'est de la fraude non non c'est pas
d'autosatisfaction mais se sait atteint
non ce sont des faits c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi ce sont les françaises et
les français qu'on fait les efforts
nécessaires comme on l'avait demandé
entre noël et jour de la cun cents
largement responsable donc vous voyez
une ambiance 13 ans portait en tout cas
jean castex a expliqué que la stratégie
vaccinale allaient se déployer montée en
charge et qu'elle allait se dérouler
selon l'ordre prévu il faudra des mois
at il dit pour vacciner des millions de
personnes mais on ne juge pas un match
de 90 minutes à la deuxième seconde at
il plaidé
et puisque l'on parle du coc vide il
faut aussi de parler d'eux
l'intervention aujourd'hui de gabriella
talent le porte parole du gouvernement
il a justifié la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'en juin on les
écoute il ya aujourd'hui dans notre pays
à la fois des mesures de portée
nationale et des mesures de portée
locale
il ya des mesures de portée nationale je
pense au couvre-feu à 20 heures je pense
au télétravail très fortement
recommandée obligatoire lorsque il est
possible dans nos entreprises
et puis il ya des applications locales
des mesures locales je pense évidemment
départements qui sont passés à 18h en
cours au feu et c'est tout à fait
logique peut se poursuivre je ne parle
pas des mesures en tant que tel je parle
du fait d'avoir à la fois un socle de
mesures nationales et des renforcements
au niveau local si c'est nécessaire
alors stéphanie vous parliez du conseil
de défense on en attend avec impatience
la conférence de presse demain de jean
castex et olivier ferrand il devrait
annoncer de nouvelles restrictions
notamment concernant le couvre-feu ce
qu'on veut à 18h sera-t-il généralisée
où va-t-il simplement s'étendre à de
nouveaux départements
on attend également des réponses sur les
écoles les cantines scolaires ou encore
la date de réouverture des universités
en tout cas l'hypothèse d'un confinement
généralisée semble heureusement ne pas
se profiler
merci à beaucoup katia technique en
direct donc de l'elysée et couvre feu
vous l'avez dit cathy à 18h sur
l'ensemble du territoire confinement le
week-end ou mise sous cloche généralisée
plusieurs options donc sur la table de
jean castex attendu demain à la tribune
à 18 heures et ce alors que le président
du conseil scientifique annonce lui ce
matin trois prochains mois difficiles à
tenir
jean françois delfraissy qui ne
préconise pas pour l'instant de fermer
des écoles contrairement à de nombreux
pays européens alors ce qu'il se dit
confiant sur la stratégie vaccinale
il se dit néanmoins inquiet au sujet de
la
nouvelle soul britannique il appelle à
trois patients on pourrait sortir en
grande partie de cette crise autour de
septembre 2021
le vaccin est la porte de sortie
n'attendons pas non plus tout du vaccin
jeudi il y a trois mois difficiles à
tenir ce sont les trois mois qui
viennent le varia anglais vient de
compliquer les choses les choses iront
un peu mieux au printemps et elle
devrait s'améliorer réellement pour la
fin de l'été
les parisiens eux se disent inquiet et
partagés au sujet de la situation
sanitaire du pays restrictions
renforcées ou non voici les réactions
propre que c'est pas très intelligent
comme la plupart des gens puisque comme
on dit tout le monde doit être dans les
transports au même moment à tout le
monde à se ruer dans les magasins même
moment moi personnellement je crois que
ça n'a pas trop changé ma vie je
travaille un peu en horaires décalés
donc voilà mais je trouve que c'est pas
une bonne mesure nouveau confinement ça
a été un peu compliqué mais bon va
falloir falloir faire avec
toujours pas de liberté pas de personne
à voir donc oui c'est un peu compliqué
surtout quand on est déjà un petit peu
un petit peu isolé et pour des raisons
sanitaires je suis complètement pour
aussi parce qu'il faut casser la chaîne
il faut que tout le monde soit de son
côté airs confiné pour arrêter parce
qu'il faut stopper à un moment c'est pas
comme ça qu'on se trouve ça c'est sûr si
on doit ré confirmé pour le bien de tout
le monde ça va être difficile mais c'est
juste une question il faut être concret
dans les choses on répond fine pour pour
plus de vaccins même si les gens il ya
certains qui émettent des doutes après
ça peut baisser les taux les taux de
contamination c'est juste le problème et
pour en parler nous sommes avec danièle
obono député la france insoumise de
paris c'est notre rubrique l'invité ce
soir bonsoir danièle obono merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france se
couvre feu sur tout le territoire à 18
heures en cette mesure raisonnable
apparemment tant au niveau sanitaire
qu'est dong et économique selon gabriel
attal vous êtes pour ou contre moi
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et je
pense que comme tous les français et
françaises et les habitants aiment tant
de ce pays
je suis assez dubitative des mesures que
prend le gouvernement on a l'impression
qu'il continue en fait à naviguer à vue
depuis plus d'un an que dure cette cette
épidémie et les propos d'ailleurs du
ministre tout à l'heure ne m'ont guère
convaincu et encore moins rassurés sur
la capacité du gouvernement à planifier
et à anticiper les prochains mois donc
je pense que je vais d'accord avec les
propos qui indiquait que les prochains
mois vont être difficiles et je crois
que la responsabilité en est en grande
partie au gouvernement donc on nous
présente le couvre-feu à 18h comme la
mesure qui permettrait d'éviter leur
confinement généralisée et en même temps
comme c'est toujours la main crohn ou
les mesures de protection sanitaire par
exemple à l'école reste notoirement
insuffisantes
au niveau des transports on est toujours
dans des situations où aux heures de
pointe
énormément de gens se retrouvent
confiné de fait en milieu de risque de
circulation on a une campagne de
vaccination qui ne répondent pas aux
propres objectifs du gouvernement qui en
faisait tout un plat etc bref tout ça
n'augure malheureusement rien de bon
sous la houlette du gouvernement
qu'auriez-vous fait différemment si vous
aviez été aux affaires la france
insoumise ce que nous proposons depuis
depuis mars dernier d'ailleurs c'est une
stratégie de planification sanitaire une
véritable planification et pas naviguer
à vue comme c'est le cas depuis trois
mois
la planification de l'organisation de la
campagne de dépistage la planification
de l'organisation d'une d'une véritable
relance économique et par exemple de
manière très pratique à l'école les la
proposition que nous mettons dans l'ain
dans le débat depuis depuis plusieurs
mois c'est celle d'une rotation
d'organiser la société par rotation avec
notamment des horaires décalés dans les
entreprises mais aussi dans les écoles
pour permettre que il y ait moins de
gens dans les lieux où doivent se faire
les enseignements c'est vrai pour
l'école primaire mais c'est vrai ça peut
être aussi le cas pour l'université on
sait la situation extrêmement difficile
aujourd'hui des étudiants isolé
précarisés en détresse psychologique
donc il faut des alternatives
effectivement au confinement des
généralités mais dès les alternatives
qui soit cohérente d'ensemble
transversale et ça c'est une proposition
que nous avons faite il y a il y
plusieurs mois maintenant qui est sur la
table mais que le gouvernement ne semble
pas vouloir prendre au sérieux en tout
cas le conseil de défense puisque de
tout
de toute évidence n'est plus tellement
le gouvernement qui décide de quoi que
ce soit c'est le conseil que le conseil
de défense et surtout emmanuel macron
qui reconnaît lui-même d'ailleurs son
propre échec puisque selon certains
journaux il se serait énervé sco suite à
l'échec de la stratégie de vaccination
d'accord ou non il semblerait que ce
déchet qu'il soit finalement comme à
beaucoup de pays européens qui navigue à
vue
comme on dit il semblerait qu'on soit
dépassée par ce virus et notamment ses
ces nouvelles variantes dont on nous
parle venue de royaume uni mais aussi
d'afrique du sud est maintenant du japon
est ce que il ya un pays qui trouve
grâce à vos yeux par exemple dans cette
gestion de la crise écoutez la situation
effectivement est toujours celle d'une
pandémie dont personne n'imagine que
cela va être réglée comme ça en quelques
semaines ou quelques mois ou que seule
la france qui arriverait donc je crois
que tout le monde a le sens des réalités
et des responsabilités lorsque nous
interrogeons que nous que nous que nous
critiquons c'est la gestion du
gouvernement qu'il fait quand même que
notre pays malgré ce qu a beau dire le
gouvernement et monsieur véran n'est pas
celui qui maîtrise le mieux la situation
nous sommes encore que ce soit pour la
question de vaccination comme c'était le
cas pour la question des tests par
exemple très en retard par rapport à
notre à d'autres voisins kiwis sont dans
une situation difficile par exemple
comme l'allemagne mais qui ont des
niveaux de tests de vaccination bien
plus bilingues bien plus important donc
est ce que on tire les leçons de ça et
ça fait pas trois mois que la l'épidémie
existe ça fait plusieurs mois et
d'autres pays des pays asiatiques même
si des mesures de renforcement ont été
prises des pays du sud est asiatique des
pays d'océanie je pense à la nouvelle
zélande
il y a des exemples ont une
planification un peu plus conséquente et
cohérente permet que la pression
sanitaires notamment soit beaucoup moins
forte que le nombre de contaminations
soit beaucoup moins fort donc oui je
pense que on a quand même des marges de
manoeuvre et d'améliorations et la
manière dont agit le gouvernement qui va
faire en sorte que la majorité
parlementaire lui octroie nouveau des
pouvoirs exorbitants et essentiellement
en termes de restriction des droits et
libertés je ne crois pas que à un pays
populations puissent vivre en état
d'urgence permanent et et je crois que
il est temps de mettre en oeuvre des
alternatives en tout cas de nous
proposons nous disons pas que tout cela
va réussir du premier coup mais il ya
des propositions sur la table que le
gouvernement continue à mépriser et ça
c'est fort dommage pas simplement parce
que c'est nous qui les proposons et
parce que en définitive on voit qu'il
est quand même en échec sur toute la
ligne
alors les vaccins 250000 personnes qui
ont eu leurs premières doses en france 1
le chic vient de tomber la france
insoumise très critique sur la part du
privé puisqu'on a appris ces derniers
jours que le cabinet américain mckinsey
intervenait dans cette stratégie de
vaccination tout comme la plateforme
privé d'octo libre donc être déjà fait
ses preuves un dr libre ça peut être une
bonne chose quand même dans
l'organisation de cette prise de rendez
vous pour les vaccins ou c'est un aveu
d'impuissance pour vous cette initiative
écoutez c'est juste la traduction de la
poursuite du projet néolibéral c'est à
dire que vous avez une stratégie depuis
des années que continuer ce gouvernement
en fait de déposséder l'état de ses
moyens d'intervention notamment de ses
moyens de stratèges vous rendez compte
que les raisons qui sont invoquées pour
faire appel à des cabinets privés dont
mackinsey mais pas que c'est le fait de
dire que on n'aurait pas les capacités
logistiques en france dans une des
premières puissances au monde pour
organiser les campagnes de vaccin donc
on a fait appel à des cabinets conseils
qui par ailleurs avait déjà conseillé
l'état et conseils l'état depuis des
années pour réduire les moyens et les
budget de l'hôpital public et pour d
investir pour que au final ce soit eux
ces cabinets privés qui ce qui est
ensuite les marchés pour mettre en place
cette logistique dont vous voyez bien
que c'est les professions auto
réalisatrice est un peu le serpent qui
se mord la queue
et oui je crois que ces accès assez
catastrophique de se rendre compte qu'on
dépend aujourd'hui des soi disant
conseil de cabinet dont l'intérêt n'est
pas l'intérêt sanitaire mais l'intérêt
l'intérêt financier
donc on pourrait parler également de doc
tony b et 2 et de la mise en place de ce
système
le problème en soi c'est pas la question
pratique parce que tout le monde et peut
convenir que c'est pratique de pouvoir m
en ligne des rendez vous est de pouvoir
organiser cela mais encore une fois
comment ça se fait que l'état des
services publics
le ministère de la santé est incapable
de mettre en oeuvre une telle une telle
infrastructure numérique
la start up nation aujourd'hui nous
explique qu' elle ne sait pas mettre en
place des rendez-vous internet du
service public et elle est obligée de le
privatiser de faire en sorte que ce soit
des parts de marché en fait voilà encore
une fois une privatisation donc enfin en
fait voilà on voit les conséquences de
l'affaiblissement de l'état comme
stratège de l'affaiblissement de
l'appareil d'état et de toutes ces
structures logistique matérielle mais
aussi numérique et qui font la joie la
joie du marché des entreprises privées
mais je pense que tout cela ne va pas
dans le sens de l'intérêt général
notamment sanitaires mais aussi
stratégique du pays merci d'amener nos
bonnes aux députés la france insoumise
de paris merci à vous la situation
sanitaire ailleurs en europe
grosse inquiétude avec la circulation
active du nouveau variant du coc vide 19
comment le vieux continent fait il face
à cette situation les détails avec
cyrielle boe face à la nouvelle vague du
coc u19
l'europe a décidé de serrer la vis dans
la ligne de mire des autorités
européennes
le variant du virus découvert au
royaume-uni largement touchés londres
veut accélérer son plan de vaccination
alors que 2,3 millions de britanniques
sont déjà vaccinés
le pays s'est fixé un nouvel objectif
les 14 millions de personnes à risques
d'ici la fin du mois de février
en plus du plan de vaccination
l'angleterre compte sur un confinement
strict pour freiner la progression du
virus la ministre de l'intérieur
britannique a averti ce mardi des
conséquences du non-respect du
confinement une minorité de personnes
mettent en danger la santé de la nation
en ne respectant pas les règles c'est
pourquoi le secrétaire d'état aux
collectivités locales a parlé
aujourd'hui au conseil le
co du rôle qu'ils ont à jouer pour faire
respecter les règles et sauver des vies
et nos agents de police seront désormais
de plus rapide pour infliger des amendes
lorsque des personnes enfreignent
clairement la réglementation concernant
le coronavirus un confinement strict
adopté par d'autres pays européens
outre la grèce et le danemark
l'allemagne opte également pour cette
solution depuis le 15 décembre dernier
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
estime à ce propos que le pays pourrait
garder cette mesure jusqu'au mois
d'avril
si la situation sanitaire ne s'améliore
pas un confinement également prolongé
aux pays bas où le nombre de
contaminations reste élevé malgré les
restrictions des mesure décriée par
certains professionnels du tourisme en
détresse financière face à la crise
sanitaire
à rome ils étaient des centaines
rassemblés pour demander au gouvernement
d'écouter leurs préoccupations nous
demandons à être écoutés parce que nous
avons été oubliés à nouveau nous avons
d'abord eu un peu d'interaction avec le
gouvernement mais maintenant nous avons
été à nouveau abandonné
nous attendons des réponses depuis le
mois de juillet nous avons eu une baisse
de 100 %
mon agence est fermé depuis le 11 mars
comme toutes les autres agences de
voyages nous parlons de dizaines de
milliers d'euros de revenus en moins
peut-être que si nous nous mettons tous
ensemble c'est des millions d'euros de
pertes
nous demandons à travailler simplement à
travailler nous voulons créer des
couloirs de santé qui permettrait à nos
clients de voyager les gens veulent
voyager il lassitude exprimée dans
d'autres pays européens
en suisse pas moins de 300 commerçants
ont décidé ce lundi de ne plus respecter
les restrictions et d'ouvrir leurs
portes aux clients pour sauver leur
entreprise
face au regain du virus l'europe semble
pourtant bien loin de vouloir assouplir
ses restrictions est le nombre des pays
et territoires on se trouve dorénavant
le variant angles s élève à 5 ans ont
des idées de 20 pour le variant
identifié en afrique du sud
tour du monde en images des nouvelle
variante de la maladie
[Musique]
et en russie à présent les limites
poutine appel à une vaccination de masse
dès la semaine prochaine selon le fonds
souverains russes plus d'un million
personnes se sont fait vacciner pour
l'instant et ce alors que près de 23000
un nouveau 4 kobe 19 ont été recensés
ces dernières heures concernant le
vaccin russe nous le pensions avant et
l'expérience le montre il est tout à
fait évident qu'il est à mon avis le
meilleur du monde
aucun autre médicament de ce genre ne
fait preuve de ce niveau de protection
et de sécurité
c'est une réussite indiscutable je vous
demande de lancer dès la semaine
prochaine une campagne de vaccination de
masse de l'ensemble de la population et
d'établir un calendrier de sa mise en
oeuvre
les directions la tunisie à présent le
ministre de la santé a annoncé dans une
conférence de presse que le gouvernement
avait décidé d'instaurer le confinement
sanitaire général à tout le pays pendant
quatre jours à partir de demain
notre reporter ben hassen chébili à
tunis nous donne plus d'explications
bonsoir basse mg prononcer correctement
votre nom ce soir quelles sont les
mesures annoncées par la ministre de la
santé et députée stéphanie c'étaient des
mesures qui sont qui était très attendu
par la population tunisienne la
population fidjienne qui ne deuxième
pack de coronavirus qui semble être
complètement incontrôlable par rapport à
la première vague la première vague
avait semble-t-il était maîtrisée par
les autorités tunisiennes qui avait
fermé les frontières ac est rapidement
qu'ils avaient fermé les écoles ainsi
que les entreprises et instauré un
couvre feu puis un confinement et pif il
semble sans doute il y à un relâchement
auprès de cette population tunisienne
d'où cette décision du gouvernement avec
une annonce du ministre de la santé lors
d'une conférence de presse de mettre en
place un nouveau confinement généralisée
à travers le pays qui devrait durer
pendant quatre jours et qui commencera à
partir de demain un couvre-feu existe
déjà en tunisie et 19 heures
le week end et 20h et la semaine mais il
y aura un nouveau couvre feu à partir de
15h demain ce qui permettra aux
tunisiens bien sûr de pouvoir aller
faire leurs courses ou à se rendre chez
le médecin mais dans un périmètre assez
est restreint autour de chez eux
et puis pendant quatre jours bien sûr et
les races ce confinement un compliment
qui pourra bien sûr être reconduit
la tunisie a eu du mal à gérer cette
deuxième vague je vous rappelle que
pendant la première vague on a eu 50
morts sur l'ensemble du territoire
et depuis on a atteint le chiffre de
5000 343 à mort c'est vous dire que la
situation est vraiment inquiétante
aujourd'hui en tunisie le gouvernement
en appelle pourtant la vigilance des
tunisiens mais les gestes de maria ne
semble pas être respectés ici sur
l'ensemble du territoire ainsi que le
port du masque est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement a instauré le
couvre-feu qui prendra bien sûr effet à
partir de demain écoles lycées
ansip université du restaurant fermé
jusqu'au 24 janvier prochain qui entre
en vigueur le jour du 10e anniversaire
de la révolution entravant ainsi toute
commémoration comment à la population
réagit-elle écoutez c'est ce qui est
surpris l'ensemble de la population
certaines personnes avec qui on a pu
échanger qui étaient étonnés juste après
cette déclaration du ministre de la
santé concernant si le couvre-feu
confinement pardon un confinement qui
prend effet le jour du 10e anniversaire
de la révolution en tunisie à savoir le
14 janvier la date semble-t-il n'a pas
été choisi au hasard pour le
gouvernement car de nombreux
rassemblements devaient être organisées
à partir de demain à travers tout le
pays surtout dans la capitale à tunis
des rassemblements des commémorations
des prises de parole est décisive le
gouvernement a voulu éditer ce
rassemblement de foule
histoire d'éviter de pouvoir propager
davantage vu riches qui semble être
incontrôlables ici en tunisie dans la
mesure où les tests pcr ne sont pas
faits en nombre et puis la suite il ne
dispose toujours pas de vaccin même si
les pistes est à l'étude avec la russie
pour acquérir le
axant le spoutnik v mais tout ça reste
encore des pourparlers entre les deux
pays est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a décidé de les choisir
cette date là pour éviter tout
rassemblement si l'incompréhension pour
l'ensemble des tunisiens qui ne
comprennent pas cette date et qui
surtout qu'ils ne comprennent pas
comment interdire de célébrer le dixième
anniversaire de la révolution
certaines personnes m'ont même dit que
malgré ces interdictions ils essaieront
de se rassembler et puis bien sûr on
verra aussi les qu'effectivement c'est
ce qui va se passer demain ou pas
merci ben hassen chébili en direct de
tunis
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous partirons aux états unis où la
chambre des représentants a entamé le
débat sur une nouvelle mise en
accusation de donald trump à une semaine
de l'investiture de joe biden et puis
nous parlerons du système électoral
américain est il à bout de souffle
ce sera l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
bien sûr il ya des choses qui changent
bien sûr le monde change
il a d'ailleurs changé entre l'enfance
du général de gaulle et 1969
ce qui ne change pas c'est la condition
humaine et une certaine idée de la
civilisation se fait de la dignité de la
personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
de salariés écrit au dessus du bureau de
chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qu'il défendit il n'y a
pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pj jones étaient
des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oublié parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il ya
quand même la liberté
je vous remercie d'avoir huit iep
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le royaume-uni va-t-il sortir gagnant du
break site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne y faisons partie de
l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout des choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir année aux
clés il est clair que bien qu lieu soit
un partenaire très puissant mieux
exporte bien plus vers le royaume uni
comme vous l'avez dit que le royaume uni
vers lui il faut bien comprendre que
c'est sur la circulation des biens et
sur la production bien c'est nous qui
sommes perdants c'est les européens
[Musique]
on parle de l'afrique comme d'un
continent en perpétuelle de vie son
dysfonctionnement actuel tient à
l'absence de redistribution à la
population par des dirigeants qui ont
une fâcheuse tendance à sugar des
poutres les pays occidentaux ont
favorisé cette dérive en encourageant le
maintien au pouvoir de politiciens de
plus en plus âgés pour assurer la
stabilité des pays et des sous régions
elles ont plus la prétention de croire
que les valeurs qu'elle défend des est
imposé par la force dans leur conquête
était universel dans cette terre des
possibles où s'esquissent les figures du
monde à venir
il faut changer notre logiciel et
arrêtez de dénigrer le faire à
l'africaine en octroyant co management à
l'anglo-saxonne
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france donald
trump est en danger évident et immédiat
pour les états unis et il doit partir
déclaration de la chef des démocrates au
congrès nancy pelosi à l'ouverture des
débats sur une nouvelle mise en
accusation du président sortant le
vice-président américain mène ce lui a
refusé un vous le savez hier soir
d'invoquer le 25e à mon nom mais la
procédure de destitution des démocrates
elle suit son cours mais des eskers
fille mike pence refuse de démettre
donald trump et s'oppose à l'invocation
du 25e amendement de la constitution
hier avant un vote crucial à la chambre
basse du congrès sur cette question le
vice-président américain a écrit une
lettre à nancy pelosi présidente de la
chambre des représentants
il estime que la démission du 45e
président des états unis desservirait le
pays
j'estime qu'un tel acte n'est pas dans
le meilleur intérêt de notre nation ni
ne correspond à la constitution d'après
notre constitution le 25e amendement
n'est pas un moyen de punition
d'usurpation l'appliquer ainsi créerait
une terrible jurisprudence
la destitution de donald trump est plus
que jamais sur la table en déplacement
dans le sud du texas ce lundi le
locataire de la maison blanche a répété
qu'il ne se sentait pas menacée et que
le 25e amendement pourrait sérieusement
entaché le mandat de son rival démocrate
je voudrais dire que la liberté
d'expression est plus que jamais menacé
le 25e amendement ne présentent aucun
risque pour moi mais il reviendra hanter
joe biden et son administration
cette lettre pousse les démocrates a
entamé un acte historique dans
l'histoire du pays à savoir le lancement
d'une deuxième procédure de destitution
à l'encontre de donald trump
de son côté nancy pelosi souhaiterait
toujours voir le président quitter ses
fonctions hier lors d'une séance pro
forma nous avons présenté une demande de
consentement unanime pour reprendre la
législation du député raskin qui demande
au vice prés
dans de mobiliser le cabinet pour
activer le 25e amendement pour démettre
à nouveau le président de ses fonctions
afin de l'empêcher de causer davantage
de dommages à notre pays dès aujourd'hui
devant la chambre
ils soumettront l'acte qui accuse le
président républicain d'avoir incité à
l'insurrection lors des événements du
capitole la semaine dernière donald
trump est censé quitter la maison
blanche le 20 janvier
autrement dit dans moins d'une semaine
et il ya une semaine le monde assiste et
éberlué à l'invasion du capitole par des
militants pro trump une scène
désastreuse que la nouvelle
administration américaine refuse de voir
se dérouler à nouveau lors de
l'investiture de joe biden la semaine
prochaine à julien euros ces images ont
fait le tour de la planète
le siège du congrès américain envahi par
une foule de manifestants
le jour où les parlementaires étaient
réunis pour confirmer la victoire de joe
biden une scène de chaos qui a marqué
les esprits alors que byden sera
officiellement investi en tant que 46e
président des états unis le 20 janvier
la capitale américaine se barricade de
nombreux américains redoute un nouveau
soulèvement et craignent pour leur
sécurité
je vis dans la peur de ces gens ces gens
des armes non pas une seule arme il
amasse des armes
ils viennent avec il n'y a pas de
détecteur de métal pour entrer dans
washington donc même s'il ya un décret
qui dit que les armes sont interdites
dans la ville il n'y a aucun moyen de le
faire appliquer ces gens des centaines
d'armes je vis dans la peur
habituellement bondées avant la
cérémonie d'investiture
la ville de sept cent mille habitants
est quasiment déserte restaurants et
commerces fermés suite à la pandémie
bâtiment protégé par des planches pour
éviter tout dégât
une situation qui fait froid dans le dos
c'est la première fois que je viens
depuis plus d'un an en général il y a
des gens partout là c'est très très
calme la ville est comme un fantôme
d'elle-même pour cette américaine
le contexte actuel pourrait logiquement
justifier que cette investiture se fasse
de manière virtuelle
je pense que ça
grillades virtuel c'était dans son
programme de tout fermer d'éviter les
rassemblements
je pense que la meilleure façon de
démontrer que c'est un aspect important
du programme c'est d'éviter qu'il y ait
une foule de gens ici le jour de
l'investiture
si pour l'instant aucun changement n'est
prévu
les risques restent tout de même présent
donald trump a annoncé depuis plusieurs
jours ne pas vouloir participer à
l'investiture
pas sûr que ses partisans en fassent
autant elle s'est donc une période
cruciale que vivent les américains
déterminant pour la fin du mandat de
donald trump et pour son avenir
politique
les explications de calais maupin
correspondant de rtl états unis il vient
à peine une semaine
des partisans de donald trump
envahissait le capitole pays a été
choqué par ces évènements et les
représentants doivent maintenant voté le
lancement d'une procédure de destitution
contre 2 valve trump afin de le mettre
en accusation devant le congrès c'est la
deuxième procédure de destitution contre
donald trump et le chef d'accusation est
incitations à l'insurrection
donald trump maintient qu'il s'agit
d'une chasse aux sorcières
il ne respecte pas la procédure et
considère qu'il s'agit d'une persécution
c'est le point de vue de donald trump
sur la question donald trump est
beaucoup critiqué du côté républicain
doit 4 beaucoup de républicains de
conservateurs ont déclaré qu'ils se
joindraient aux efforts des démocrates
contre donald trump pour le mettre en
accusation lancer une procédure et
peut-être même aller jusqu'à la
destitution comme l'a affirmé la
représentante républicaine liz cheney
donald trump est le troisième président
de l'histoire des états unis à être
soumis à une procédure de destitution
pour le président andrew johnson la
procédure a été lancée mais n'a pas
abouti en procédure de destitution a
également été ouverte contre bill
clinton après le scandale monica
lewinsky sans aboutir non plus
donald trump avait déjà été soumis à une
procédure de destitution
suite à sa discussion téléphonique avec
le président ukrainien
il s'agit de sa deuxième certains se
demandent si donald trump pourrait être
le premier président à quitter le
pouvoir suite à une procédure de
destitution
richard nixon a démissionné lorsqu'on a
lancé la procédure à son encontre
il a dû quitter le pouvoir avant que la
procédure ait véritablement commencée
donald trump devrait quitter le pouvoir
le 20 janvier lorsque joe biden prêtera
serment en tant que président
la démarche est donc surtout symbolique
les démocrates disent qu'ils souhaitent
cette destitution afin que donald trump
ne puisse plus jamais être candidat il
deviendrait inéligible à la présidence
c'est un moment important
historique au capitole le congrès réagi
très fortement aux événements d'il ya
une semaine
la sonde du capitole par des
manifestants pro tran des tensions sont
toujours très vive dans le pays dans le
sillage des événements de la semaine
dernière
il reste à voir si cela mènera à la
destitution et au départ de donald trump
et une semaine après ces événements du
capitole l'amérique est toujours groggy
est l'une des plus anciennes et les plus
ambitieuses démocratie du monde est sous
le choc après cette élection
présidentielle extrêmement contestée
alors le système électoral américain est
il à bout de souffle la démocratie
américaine est-elle archaïque
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage ce
soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois durpaire historien spécialiste
des états unis bonsoir françois durpaire
merci d'être avec nous à vos côté gérald
ollivier journaliste essayiste franco
américain bonsoir également avons
général de olivier alors une semaine
après l'intrusion dans l'enceinte du
capitole à washington se barricade et
élèves la sécurité regarder tout d'abord
les images de ces soldats rendormi
arrivés en renfort sur place
est ce qu'il faut craindre clairement
une réaction des supporters de trump en
colère la semaine prochaine au moment de
l'investiture de joe biden françois
durpaire
en tout cas c est pris très au sérieux
parce que cette menace est elle est
effectivement à la fois sur washington
et sur les 50 capital d'état le fbi a
quelque chose à se faire pardonner
puisque on sait depuis plusieurs heures
que qu'un rapport du fbi aille de son
antenne plus précisément de virginie
avait alerté sur la possibilité d
événements du 6 janvier des événements
du capitole est-ce que la menace donc
n'a pas été prise au sérieux pourtant
pourtant le fbi de virginie avait
souligné qu'il y avait des groupes
d'extrême droite qui était en train de
s'organiser qui avait récupéré les plans
du capitole et que plusieurs de ces
groupes les masses étaient mis en lien
pour se coordonner ce jour là donc c'est
l'inquiétude est donc le fbi avait bien
essaye dans la perspective de
l'investiture de ne pas reproduire les
failles du 6 janvier dernier
gérald olivier justement donné en train
de parler de cette colère il a mis en
garde contre cette colère de ses
militants de ses partisans après qu'on
l'ait bayonnais il parle de chasse aux
sorcières ça y est
on y est réellement dans le dur de cette
colère en tous les cas on est dans le
dur
comment dirais-je d'une tentative par un
certain nombre de pouvoirs politiques et
par un certain nombre de médias avoir
par un certain nombre de sociétés de ce
qu'on appelle le big tech de mettre un
terme au mouvement mcc à un magal et
quatre initiales de mecs america great
games parce que au delà de la
destitution qui est en train ou qui sera
voté aujourd'hui par la chambre des
représentants
on a eu un certain nombre de élus qui
ont soutenu et donald trump qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui menacé on demande
la démission ou le bannissement de tête
cruz
donc il y à un mouvement qui dépasse
très largement la personne de donald 30
mais moi ce que je voudrais rappeler et
j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce qu'a dit
françois à l'instant et il a tout à fait
raison de rappeler le fait que
aujourd'hui on apprend que le fbi a est
pas rien que le fbi a également le
commissariat de police fin le nypd le
département de police de new york avait
reçu différentes informations indiquant
qu'il pourrait y avoir des violences à
l'occasion du discours du président et
c'est extrêmement important parce que je
rappelle que la chambre des
représentants va voter la destitution de
donald trump la deuxième destitution sur
le motif qu'il aurait incité à la
violence
comment peut-on inciter à la violence
des gens qui ont déjà prémédité des
violences donc vous avez un véritable
problème juridique qui se posent sur la
validité de l'acte d'accusation que ce
que si on veut destituer le président il
faut rédiger ce qu'on appelle des
articles 9 impeachment donc des articles
de destitution qui constitue une sorte
de mise en accusation du président donc
premier problème sur le fond de cette
mise en accusation et vous avez un
second problème sur la forme
dans la mesure où le vote de la chambre
doit être suivi d'un procès au sénat
procès qui n'aura sans doute pas le
temps de se tenir avant la fin du mandat
de donald trump
tout en sachant qu'il est très peu
vraisemblable
à l'issue de ce procès vous ayez un vote
à une majorité des deux tiers ce qui
signifierait que la moitié du camp
républicain se rallie aux camps
démocrates pour voter contre trump donc
c'est une procédure qui est très
contestable sur le fond et sur la forme
sur cette procédure on rappelle que le
vice président mike pence a refusé
d'invoquer 25e amendement arrière contre
donald trump regarder avant de faire
réagir françois durpaire ce qu'il écrit
à 26 pelosi dans cette lettre le 25e
amendement n'est pas un moyen de
punition ou d'usurpation l'appliquer
ainsi créerait une terrible
jurisprudence je ne céderai pas
maintenant aux efforts de la chambre des
représentants pour jouer à des jeux
politiques à un moment aussi grave dans
la vie de notre nation
françois durpaire objectivement y at il
des raisons juridiques légitime de
destituer donald trump où il ya une
arrière-pensée démocrate derrière cette
initiative alors la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement la charge qui est
choisi par les démocrates et la pire
charge de l'histoire des états unis
puisqu'il s'agit d' incitation
volontaire à l'insurrection c'est la
plus grave
la deuxième chose c'est que vous avez vu
que le vice président a été en quelque
sorte contraint de répondre
j avais déjà eu lettre de nancy pelosi
mais là c'est beaucoup plus formel
c'était un vote de 223 voix contre 205
qui demande auprès au vice président le
25e amendement est donc là il a été
obligé d'argumenter et de dire pourquoi
il ne le souhaitait pas oui il y à une
arrière fond politique très planète
l'idée des démocrates c'est de dire on
va pouvoir peut-être divisés les
républicains sur cette affaire parce que
certains républicains lors d'une part
voudrait peut-être se débarrasser d'un
treuil pour 2024 mais certains autres
pourraient vouloir s'en débarrasser pour
les mythes terme dans deux ans et vous
voyez déjà commencé à se fissurer
ce parfum finalement de la destitution
liz cheney
notamment qui a été cité dans votre
reportage qui a été dit est tout à fait
juste parce que c'est important sans
rapport du fbi aïssa permet non
seulement à donald trump d'être
d'empêcher dit me kiejman mais c'est pas
forcément plus grave lynch m ce qui
était peut-être le plus grave c'est
l'accusation criminelle
or vous le savez que si l' enquête
fédérale détermine que les responsables
de la mort notamment d'officiers de
police technique et bien on trie
finalement à la lettre le discours du
président donald trump est bien le code
pénal fédéral érigent en infraction le
fait d'inciter à la violence
mais s'il ya effectivement un rapport du
fbi haye montrant que tout cela était
organisé
bien avant le discours du président sem
america et bien tous les propos du
président train vous savez cette
dernière phrase allons marcher sur le
capitole et montrons ayant l'audace et
reprenons notre pays est bien toutes ces
propos pèserait peu de choses devant un
juge
si effectivement eh bien on pouvait
prouver que tout avait été organisé
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
avant le discours du président une chose
est sûre c'est que cette colère des
partisans de donald trump elle et trouve
son origine dans le fait qu'ils pensent
qu'ils ne sont convaincus on l'a vu avec
tous ces témoignages qu'on a entendu ils
sont convaincus tout simplement qu'on
leur a volé leur élection qu'il ya eu
des fraudes massives
certains montrent du doigt aujourd'hui
ce système de vote électoral aux états
unis écoutez par exemple le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe après les
élections sergueï lavrov ils ont sans
doute le système électoral le plus
archaïque existants parmi les quelques
pays les plus importants au monde
alors c'est vrai que je le disais ce
système beaucoup le remette en cause sa
aurait pas été plus simple finalement
d'avoir un suffrage direct
une voix un électeur que ces histoires
de grands électeurs qui ont déjà causé
un petit peu de temps par le passé on se
souvient d'élections al gore bush
gérald
vié non ce ne sont pas les grands
électeurs qui sont en cause ce qui est
en cause pour loi de manière évidente
c'est le vote par courrier
et d'ailleurs quand vous regardez cette
élection au delà donc qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi est ce que les
supporters de trump sont si convaincus
que l'élection leur a été volé alors que
tous les recours en justice du président
on compte été rejetée pas tous mais la
plupart parce qu'en fait l'élection et
se résume à ceci les démocrates ont dit
on compte tous les bulletins les
républicains ont dit on compte tous les
bulletins légitime ou les bulletins
légaux et en même temps que les
démocrates vous dise en compte tous les
bulletins
eh bien on prend prétexte de la pandémie
de coronavirus pour inonder les
électeurs de bulletins de vote par
correspondance
certains certains américains ont
témoigné avoir reçu plusieurs bulletins
à leur nom un deux trois voire quatre
bulletins dans ce cas là une même
personne peut voter
quatre fois et c'est tout à fait légal
puisque la règle a été rentré dans le
système en même temps que l'on multiplie
les bulletins de vote par correspondance
un certain nombre d'états ont réduit
vérifier la validité un bulletin de vote
par correspondance je vous rappelle il
est identifié par son enveloppe sur l'
enveloppe extérieure
l'électeur doit porter sa signature et
cette signature doit être comparé à la
signature qui est sur les listes
électorales et si c'est la même
signature le bulletin est validé si la
signature est différente
le bulletin est invalidée en dans un
certain nombre d'états dont les états
décisifs de la pennsylvanie du nevada de
la géorgie on a réduit au minimum les
capacités de vérification pour valider
le plus grand nombre de bulletins
possible donc ce dont se plaignent les
électeurs de donald trump c'est qu'on a
permis à un certain nombre de bulletins
qui n'aurait pas dû être validé de
lettres et il n'y a pas de violations la
règle avait pris soin d'être évoluer
d'être votée par les législatures ou aux
besoins validé par les sucres les cours
suprêmes des différents états al avance
donc en fait c'est pas du tout le
système des grands électeurs le problème
pour moi c'est le système du vote par
correspondance
et le fait que dans certains états le
vote a été compté dépouillés dans la
nuit même alors que dans d'autres il
s'est prolongé sur plusieurs jours et
qu'on a admis de recevoir des bulletins
et de vanité des bulletins qui avaient
été reçus en retard là je crois que la
mort de deux choses à changer bien sûr
le système des grands électeurs auraient
peut-être effectivement le le mérite
d'être plus simple parce que six
millions de votes voilà quand ce sont
des électeurs direct on les voit
largement il n'empêche pour revenir
cette affaire de vote par correspondance
donald trump avait effectivement prévu
prévenu avant l'élection qu'elle
entraînerait des fraudes massives selon
lui on rappelle françois durpaire que
quand même en france on l'a supprimée en
1975 pour éviter des fraudes
j'en reviens à ma question initiale est
ce que cette démocratie américaine ce
process électorale n'est pas un petit
peu au bout à bout de souffle n'est pas
un petit peu archaïque
alors ce qui est tout à fait d'accord
avec avec gerald pour dire que cette
question des grands électeurs n'est pas
en cause d'ailleurs si les grands
électeurs les grands électeurs devaient
être réformé ça ne serait pas en faveur
du parti républicain on le sait il ya
des propositions de réforme de ce
système des grands électeurs pour aller
notamment dans le champ c'est bien d'une
valorisation plus importante des grands
centres urbains des états qui ont pris
du poids ou pour des dernières années
c'est plutôt en faveur des démocrates
c'est pas du tout la question des camps
des lecteurs c'est la question du vote
par correspondance
la question du vote par correspondance
et bien elle a d'abord un contexte le
contexte c'est lakovic 19
jamais dans l'histoire des états unis il
y avait eu autant de possibilités
offertes par les législatures de ce vote
par correspondance et donald trump a
très finement joué pourquoi il a très
finement joué parce que depuis des mois
et des mois il dit ce vote par
correspondance
n'y allez pas c'est un vote qui va être
tronqué
du coup qui est aller plutôt vers le
vote par correspondance plutôt des
démocrates les républicains se sont
déplacés imaginez que ces votes par
correspondance soit à 50/50 républicains
ou démocrates et que le président depuis
le départ n'est rien dit sur le vote par
correspondance
et bien il y aurait passé polémique sur
le vote par correspondance parce que
autant les républicains que les
démocrates auraient voté par
correspondance et donc on ne serait pas
aujourd'hui à parler de cette question
du vote par correspondance tout
simplement
geraldo olivier ma dernière question
donne un train qui ne sera pas présent
pour l'investiture de joe biden à la
passation de pouvoir s'est aussi cette
image que va retenir l'histoire aux
états unis oui je pense en partie
malheureusement je dis bien
malheureusement
néanmoins je pense qu'il a raison de ne
pas être présents parce que surtout avec
les événements de la semaine dernière sa
présence serait peut-être perturbante
donald trump a la capacité d'attirer les
projecteurs sur lui et je pense que là
il doit laisser la place à son
successeur
c'est aussi sa façon de dire qu'il ne
reconnaît pas la validité de l'élection
même si il se retirer il laisse les
institutions se produire et la
transition se passe et je dirais dans un
calme relatif
le mot de la fin françois durpaire oui
mais on va effectivement suivre cette
journée d'investiture
pour beaucoup c'est finalement le
dernier pied de nez de notre aux
institutions de son pays pour d'autres
de n'attrape n'est pas fini
politiquement la question que pose et
gerald est intéressant tout à l'heure
sont-ce aux réseaux sociaux de
débrancher politiquement l'homme le plus
puissant du monde est ce que les réseaux
sociaux notamment twitter mais également
google et facebook ne sont pas en train
de dire nous sommes plus puissant que
l'homme le plus puissantes du monde
c'est nous qui à l'avenir feront et duff
défairont les rois de deux secondes
c'est un véritable impeachment numérique
c'est un autre débat effectivement
françois du rhdp remercié avons gerald
bolivie
également d'avoir été avec nous en
direct dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur le point presse de jean
castex en france sur la situation
sanitaire qui doit avoir lieu demain
parmi les pistes étudiées par l'exécutif
la généralisation du couvre-feu à 18h
sur tout le territoire
et puis nous irons au liban un couvre
feu total est imposée à partir de demain
et ce pendant 11 jours même les magasins
d'alimentation seront fermés
[Musique]
sonic a recruté dans toutes les couches
de la société sans faire de tri des
mineurs des femmes des délinquants des
criminels de droit commun tout le monde
est venu à jaca en syrie il ya encore
quelques quelques années au moment de
charlie hebdo l'eau ou du bataclan il y
avait un état islamiste qui semblait
diriger tout ça la bascule et se fait
justement en 2015 et smith est un peu le
passage de relais d'al qaïda l'état
islamique quelque part dans notre
politique internationale vis bien
évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement on
recrutement l'a malheureusement fait en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
comment on peut expliquer qu'elle un
groupe énorme comme areva qui est
spécialisé puisse acheter des mines
inexploitables ce n'est pas explicable
mais ça permet d'envoyer aussi des
gratifications on va dire avait à des
politiciens nigérien la gestion
fantaisiste d'areva a des répercussions
incroyable jusqu'au président américain
obama donne son accord pour qu'areva
bénéficie d'un prêt de 2 milliards de
dollars alors que l'agent ce qui est
censé gérer ces prêts un avis négatif
je ne suis pas pour ou contre le
nucléaire je suis simplement pour une
industrie sans corruption parce que
cette industrie là si elle crée un
incident
c'est pour l'éternité
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé
donnait le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
au loin de paris mais toujours loin de
ce qu'il est guéri majoritaire mâcon et
passe un tour de tracteur avec nos
campagnes il faut savoir c'est qu'une
vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas forêts et aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qui va là c'est fini pour moi
est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que notre
peuple
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inné gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire espace en direct puisque
on est on dirait qu'il ya quand même la
liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ça soit réduire
le débat de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'ils une histoire de vie et
de mort
il faut protéger la végétation faut
protéger la faune il faut protéger notre
santé
tout ça c y et n'oublions pas que tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise je suis poli
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pensait deuxième heure d'émission tout
de suite voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce mercredi 13 janvier prise de
parole attendu demain de jean castex la
crise sanitaire au coeur d'un conseil de
défense maintenant alors que le pays a
encore trois mois difficiles à tenir
selon jean françois delfraissy
parmi les pistes étudiées par l'exécutif
la généralisation du couvre-feu à 18h
sur tout le territoire
près de deux cent cinquante mille
personnes ont reçu une première dose du
vaccin ce jour l'inquiétude demeure sur
le variant anglais mais aussi sud
africain qui se trouve désormais dans 50
pays
l'om est au pays du cèdre les mesures
sont drastiques ouvre fleurs posées à
partir de jeudi pendant 11 jours
même les magasins d'alimentation seront
fermées ou libanais qui se sont rués
aujourd'hui dans les supermarchés un
seul mot d'ordre donc rester chez soi
alors que les contaminations sont
répartis à la hausse et que les hôpitaux
sont saturés
[Musique]
le nombre de chrétiens tués pour leur
foi dans le monde a augmenté de 60 % en
2020 un terrible constat de
l'association protestante évangélique
portes ouvertes qui publie aujourd'hui
de nouvelles statistiques
c'est en afrique subsaharienne et plus
particulièrement au nigeria que les
chiffres sont les plus hauts alors que
sévissent des groupes dziwisz
la force dans le viseur de l'om jean
human right watch l'organisation
américaine publie son rapport
aujourd'hui et s'inquiète du projet de
loi de sécurité globale en france et
plus précisément son article 24 qui veut
empêcher la prise de vue des forces de
police lors des manifestations
elle dénonce également les amalgames
notamment matière d'islam et de menaces
terroristes sera l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
un nouveau conseil de défense a eu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée au menu notamment
le possible renforcement des mesures
sanitaires déjà en place alors que
faut-il attendre de la conférence de
presse de jean castex demain à 18h
éléments de réponse avec quentin
mauclair la pression s'accentue sur le
gouvernement alors que la situation
sanitaire se dégrade et que les effets
des fêtes de fin d'année commence à être
observés un nouveau conseil de défense
ainsi qu'un conseil des ministres se
sont tenues ce mercredi au terme de ces
réunions de l'exécutif
le porte parole du gouvernement est
revenu sur l'efficacité du couvre-feu à
18h en place dans certains départements
manifestement il y a un effet sur la
circulation du virus de l'avancement du
couvre-feu à 18 heures et ce qui nous a
été démontrée ce matin à l'appui de
données et de statistiques c'est que
dans les départements où le couvre-feu a
été avancée à 18h au tout début du mois
de janvier la circulation du virus est
moins importante que dans d'autres
départements français à dire qu'il croît
moins vite alors que le premier ministre
s'exprimera ce jeudi plusieurs
possibilités pour renforcer des mesures
en place s'offrent au gouvernement
tout d'abord un couvre-feu à 18h
généralisé sur l'ensemble du territoire
la deuxième option coupe leur ait le
couvre feu généralisé à 18 heures un
confinement le week end
enfin la piste la moins probable mais
nos confinement général des français
le premier ministre a récemment indiqué
qu'il ne fallait pas exclure un
troisième confinement en dernier recours
quid également des écoles le taux de
positivité des tests chez les moins de
20 ans ayant augmenté la semaine
dernière la question de la fermeture des
établissements pourraient revenir sur le
tapis
dans le même temps le président du
conseil scientifique jean françois
delfraissy appelle l'exécutif à prendre
des décisions rapides notamment pour
freiner la propagation du variant
anglais si on ne fait rien si on ne
prend pas très rapidement des décisions
on aura une extension du variant anglais
on est dans une sorte de course de
vitesse entre d'une part l'apparition
inéluctable de ce variant anglais qui
peut nous conduire à des chiffres de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes touchées
si on se projette début
il est d'autre part la capacité à
vacciner les personnes les plus fragiles
nous sommes dans cette course pour les
trois mois qui viennent extension du
couvre-feu fermeture des écoles
propagation du variant anglais dans
l'hexagone ou encore accélération de la
campagne de vaccination
le premier ministre jean castex tentera
de répondre à ces problématiques lors
d'une nouvelle conférence de presse
prévue ce jeudi à 18 heures et pour en
parler nous sommes avec enrique café
l'innocent chef des urgences à l'hôpital
bichat à paris
bonsoir et habiter casalino merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
professionnel que vous êtes attend quoi
de jean castex demain je pense que les
professionnels de santé comme les
citoyens nous attendons d'éviter que
dans les mois à venir nous commission
permanence une situation difficile une
situation difficile sanitaire avec
beaucoup de passion l hôpital beaucoup
de patients en réanimation mais aussi
une situation sociale et économique
difficile pour chacun des français tous
les français ont consenti beaucoup
d'efforts
il faut qu'on ait une certaine
lisibilité moi je préfèrerais avoir une
période un peu plus strictes maintenant
mais à voir les perspectives des
vacances de février où tous les français
peuvent éventuellement passer du temps
avec leur famille avec leurs enfants
il faudra faire sûrement consentir au
corps des efforts mais il faut qu'il y
ait une lisibilité et qu'on s'acheminait
ou un gain pour bien qu'on comprenne
henrique casalino par exemple dans votre
hôpital à bichât quel est l'état des d
urgence des services de réanimation à ce
qu'ils sont saturés où ça tient encore
non nous sommes à paris en région
parisienne dans une zone avec un taux de
dons un taux d'incidence intermédiaire
aux alentours de 200 donc nous avons
beaucoup de patients il ya en permanence
des demandes de lits d'hospitalisation
il ya en permanence soldé besoin de lits
de réanimation mais nous ne sont pas
saturés
ce n'est pas le cas des villes de l'est
de la france où la demande est beaucoup
plus
importante les taux d'incidence sont
supérieurs à 250
il ya beaucoup plus de demandes de
patients devine les réanimations les
taux d'occupation sont beaucoup plus
élevés nous avons aussi des demandes de
patients qui ont des problèmes et qui
ont besoin de l'hôpital et donc il
existe une tension beaucoup plus
importante donc il est vrai que la
réalité dans l'est de la france n'est
pas la même que nos l'ouest et si je
peux comprendre des règles des solutions
nationales
il faut quand même avoir une granularité
et que les décisions soient les plus
adaptées aux réalités de chaque région
legrand est évidemment chacun s'en
souvient c'était la première région très
frappé l'une des régions les plus
frappées à de france
au début on devait même trier les
patients comment vous expliquer
aujourd'hui que à nouveau cette région
soit parmi les plus frappés de france
nous n'avons pas une explication très
clair on peut y poster climatique parce
que c'est une région plus froids dont on
peut imaginer que ce sont des régions
des frontières où il ya beaucoup de
passages transfrontaliers
on peut imaginer également que ce sont
des zones industrielles industriels il y
a une activité et commerciales plus
importantes mais nous n'avons pas une
explication très clair quoi qu'il en
soit il ya un gradient très claire de
l'est vers l'ouest et que et les
solutions doivent être le plus adapté
pour que chacun sente ce que ce qu'il
fait ce sacrifice qu'il m'a accordée
parce que c'est vraiment un sacrifice il
est justifié
il est cohérent et il lui permet
d'obtenir lui même un avantage c'est la
certitude qu'il va pouvoir avoir un
horizon est ce que l'horizon c'est les
vacances de février
est-ce que l'horizon c'est la fin de
l'hiver une période un peu plus sereine
des activités pour rendre un peu
reprendre
même si elles ne reprendront pas de
façon normale je pense que dans les mois
qui viennent mais au moins qu'il puisse
y avoir une certaine reprise ce désastre
justement il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
vis-à-vis de ce variant angles est
maintenant sud africain des labos
francilien nous explique d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui que selon eux 10 à 15% des
cas en ile de france serait ce variant
anglais ça veut dire que si on ne réagit
pas tout de suite et qu'on fera pas fort
la situation va empirer notamment en ile
de france
nous allons voir se développer de plus
en plus de variants le club
le propre d'un virus et qu'il mute et
plus ils circulent plus il mute parce
que pour muter il faut qu'ils circulent
s'ils ont bloqué la circulation
complètement il n'y aurait pas de
mutation donc moi j'avais entendu 1% des
souchon en france étaient liés aux arts
et aux anglais je vous rappelle qu'il a
le maillot sud-africain il est le
variant brésilien qui pose aussi des
problèmes
aujourd'hui il va falloir qu'on se
prépare à l'idée que le virus peut
connaître des mutations que ces
mutations ces nouveaux variants peuvent
conférer des nouveaux caractères
faciliter la transmission des virus
peut-être même le rendre plus pathogène
plus virulents avec plus de mobilité ou
de mortalité est aussi peut-être plus
résistants à certains traitements voire
mettre en échec la stratégie vaccinale
mais tout ça pour le moment ce sont des
risques théoriques
ce qui est important c'est de redoubler
les efforts ce qui marche c'est les
règles de distanciation règle l'arrière
et c'est ça que nous devons redoubler
d'efforts et savoir qu'ici les rien
sacrifices c'est pour éviter que la
situation se dégrade et que nous
connaissions encore une vraie
augmentation de la transmission dans le
cadre l'angleterre je l' ai déjà dit et
je le répète l'angleterre aurait dû
confiner même s'il n'y avait pas eu le
variant angles est parce qu en
angleterre il n'y a eu aucun aucune
règle imposée de de réduction des
risques au bar des derricks
barrières et des règles de distanciation
social il n'y avait rien comme nous on
l'a fait en france et c'est ça qui
explique qu'il y à une souche qui est
apparu que maintenant il est une
explosion du nombre de cas et variantes
opa variante l'angleterre ont reconnu
une pic épidémique extrêmement important
donc nous devons redoubler d'efforts et
faire très attention pour éviter que des
rêves où le nouveau à riom où le virus
classique
nous mettons difficulté on entend bien
votre appel à respecter les gestes
barrières et d'une certaine manière à
espérer peut-être des restrictions plus
sévères pour peut-être un petit peu
mieux vivre après vous vous êtes
peut-être moins exprimé sur le vaccin
250000 français qui ont reçu la première
dose
aujourd'hui c'est une porte de sortie
encourageante
selon vous où jean françois delfraissy
du conseil académique nous dit
scientifique pardon nous dit voilà on a
encore trois mois très difficiles ça ira
mais au printemps voir à la fin de l'été
on sera peut-être tiré d'affaires ce
vaccin c'est le salut pour vous aussi
c'est évident que si nous avons une
stratégie vaccinale ambitieuse
officieuse sable viril foresti n'est 60%
ou 70% de la population au minimum après
on peut commencer par les personnes les
plus fragiles sont ensemble cohérent et
protéger la population à plus haut
risque de décès ou des formes graves
toucher 60 ou 70% de la population
ça veut dire quand même probablement 40
ou 45 millions de français il faut quand
même que ce soit fait avant le printemps
est très clairement avant l'automne
prochain
dire que il ya un horizon un moment
tendre pour lequel on se dit que ça va
arrêter il faut pas oublier non plus que
ce virus circule et qu'il mute et qui ne
circulent pas que dans l'hémisphère nord
que dans les pays riches il circule
aussi dans l'hémisphère sud dans des
pays où dans la capacité à vacciner sa
population va être inférieure
et si nous nous contentons de vacciner
seulement en france où seulement dans
les pays développés ou riches
le virus va continuer la série
et dans d'autres régions du globe va
connaître des mutations actuellement il
ya des pays qui sont en très grande
difficulté et pas muté va connaître des
évolutions et il pourrait revenir avec
des mutations qui pourraient échapper
par exemple au vaccin
donc aujourd'hui la communauté mondiale
plus que jamais doit être unie et c'est
un effort mondial qui doit être fait
pour que tous les peuples tous les tous
les habitants de la planète ont tous les
habitants de la terre qu'ils
bénéficiaient de la vaccination casalino
vous le voyez bien en europe on n'a même
pas les doses suffisantes
vous voyez l'inquiétude qui est la
mienne
moi je pense qu'en france nous devons
vacciner vacciner vacciner vacciner les
populations fragiles vacciner pas
seulement les personnes très âgées mais
les patients diabétiques les patients
immunodéprimés
les patients qui ont un cancer toutes
les personnes qui pourraient être
exposés à une forme grave de la maladie
nous devons donc exigeants et patiner
mais nous devons avec la même exigence
demandé que toutes les populations de la
planète soit exigé la production
industrielle on va pas me faire croire
que ce n'est pas possible de faire quand
il ya une guerre regarder la deuxième
guerre mondiale
l'augmentation massive de la production
d'armements s'est fait en quelques mois
on va pas me faire croire que
aujourd'hui l'industrie pharmaceutique
ne veut pas très rapidement augmenter de
façon massive au sa capacité de
production des vaccins pour protéger la
population mondiale
c'est indispensable on ne peut pas faire
autrement c'est un problème est dit que
c'est un problème moral c'est un
problème politique
c'est en prendre un problème de
conscience politique de tout l'est dont
tous les peuples de notre planète
merci beaucoup et henrique casalino chef
des urgences à l'hôpital bichat à paris
allez on le plus grand centre de
dépistage de kobe 19 fait appel aux
étudiants en quatrième année médecine
pour effectuer des tests
une participation basé sur le
volontariat de ses futurs médecins mais
une démarche qui inquiète certains
d'entre eux reportage luis carballo avec
solène gaulle à prêter main forte
oui mais pas à n'importe quel prix stage
déguisé rémunération modique et absence
de contrat de travail
dans un communiqué posté sur les réseaux
sociaux ce lundi les organisations
étudiantes de l'université lyon sud
dénoncent les conditions dans lesquelles
des étudiants de 4e année de médecine
sont mobilisés par le plus grand centre
de prélèvement de la ville pour faire
passer des tests ducobu 19
on estime cette émission de dépistage
sont ne font pas partie des missions
premières d'un étudiant hospitalier et
qu'elles doivent être encadrés par un
vrai contrat de travail et par une
rémunération qui leur sont propres ya
seulement un intérêt économique l
employé un étudiant hospitalier en
médecine basque il est payé seulement de
0,62 l'heure et puis bah forcément
déplacées les étudiants au lieu
d'employer du vrai personnel pour
dépister va ça peut faire des économies
des étudiants qui regrette également que
cette mission de dépistage soit décompté
de leur semaine de stage à l'hôpital et
qui mettent en doute son caractère
volontaire pratiquer faire des pcr à la
chaîne pour des étudiants en médecine
pendant une semaine n'a aucun intérêt
pédagogique
le centre de dépistage du palais des
sports de gerland espère recevoir l'aide
de 15 à 20 étudiants par semaine sur
huit à douze semaines lors de la
première vague épidémique
ce sont les étudiants en médecine de
l'université de lyon est qu'ils ont été
appelés en renfort
interrogé par nos confrères de france 3
le professeur laurent responsable de ce
centre de dépistage met en avant une
contribution bénéfique pour les
étudiants une très grande partie
d'étudiants se sont plus aptes à faire
des prélèvements
à l'issue de cette semaine au centre de
dépistage
depuis le 26 septembre 2020 plus de
55000 prélèvement nasopharyngé ont été
réalisés dans ce centre de dépistage
grâce notamment aux étudiants en
médecine face à une épidémie qui
continuent de progresser en france
les représentants des étudiants de lyon
sud craignent que leur mobilisation se
pérennise
et puis au liban je le disais en titre
le taux de contamination a grimpé en
flèche après les fêtes les autorités
imposent à partir de demain en
jours de confinement total tous les
secteurs du pays seront mis sous cloche
à l'exception des services de santé
maxine un maxima baer des queues
interminables à l'entrée des rayons
bondés
depuis le début de la semaine les
magasins d'alimentation de beyrouth sont
pris d'assaut
plus de 1700 morts ces derniers jours le
qu'ovide n'en finit plus de progresser
au libre en une semaine
trente mille nouveaux cas ont été
détectés dans un pays de six millions
d'habitants un chiffre qui en proportion
équivaut à 300 milles contamination
hebdomadaire dans un pays comme la
france les autorités libanaises ne cache
pas que la situation est préoccupante
le président de la république a évoqué
la gravité de la situation sanitaire
résultant de la propagation de la
pandémie de coronavirus les hôpitaux ne
sont plus en mesure de recevoir des cas
et nous avons vu des scènes tragiques
impliquant des citoyens attendant devant
les hôpitaux à la recherche d'un lit
face à la saturation des hôpitaux les
autorités ont décrété lundi l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et un bouclage total
du pays
il est interdit de sortir dans la rue et
sur les routes entre 5 heures du matin
le jeudi 14 janvier 2021 et 5 heures du
matin le lundi 25 janvier des mesures
drastiques en vigueur pendant 11 jours
et qui font souffler un vent de panique
sur la population
tout le monde veut faire des provisions
surtout ceux qui ont des enfants je
m'inquiète de ce que je peux trouver
pour mes enfants avant de penser à moi
le pays sera entièrement bouclé pas le
droit d'aller faire ses courses de
l'exercice ou de promener son chien
les frontières terrestres et maritimes
seront également fermés à tous les
voyageurs sauf à disposer d'un visa
haddock
ces mesures s'ajoutent à un contexte
déjà difficile dans le pays du cèdre
beaucoup de secteurs s'effondre
économiquement ceux qui ne meurent pas
du coronavirus meurent de faim ceux qui
ne peuvent pas télétravail est par
exemple vont perdre leur salaire en
restant chez eux
je peux me permettre de rester à la
maison pendant dix jours
mais il ya des gens qui vont mourir de
faim s'ils doivent rester à la maison
pendant dix jours les hôpitaux privés
représentent au liban plus de 80% du
secteur hospitalier
contrainte d'augmenter la capacité de
leur unité de soins intensifs
ces structures sont toujours dans
l'attenté du paiement d'arriérés par
l'état
conséquence certains établissements
resigne parfois accueillir des patients
atteints du coc vie 19 avec une hausse
de 70% des contaminations par rapport à
la semaine précédente
le liban fait partie des pays
connaissant l'une des plus fortes
progressions dans le monde derrière le
portugal le nigeria ou encore l'irlande
le pays doit recevoir en février sa
première livraison du vaccin
feiler bio ntech et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis beyrouth au
liban avec un jacques un choc est
réflexologue à l'hôpital hôtel-dieu de
beyrouth c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques joker merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france un
confinement bras stick 1 on vient de le
voir est ce qu on avait le choix
seulement vous oui bonsoir en fait à mon
avis on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix et en fait je crois qu'il devrait
y avoir auparavant des actions
préventives en fait l'ailé des jours de
fête ont été un tout petit peu
permissive il ya eu plein de l'un contre
le jour de la saint sylvestre
et puis après on se paye maintenant les
pots cassés donc avec cette augmentation
drastique des cas des milliers par jour
du jamais vu depuis la première vague en
fait et depuis même le blast 2 be good
donc le quatre hôtes se passer donc là
on est dans une situation très critique
en fait avec tout à fait quand vous
devenez de bien de le dire dans votre
reportage les les hôpitaux qui sont
saturés les les lits de soins intensifs
et qui sont un pari une partie
limitantes qui sont saturés et donc bon
je crois que on n'avait pas le choix on
doit actuellement faire ce confinement
ce lock out total
effectivement on reportage on entendait
un des personnes qui faisait avec eux un
devant les hôpitaux à beyrouth au liban
pour espérer obtenir un lit est ce que à
l'instar du grand test au début de la
pandémie est ce que il ya ce sinistre
tri des patients au liban vous en est
arrivé là également vous avez été
contraints de faire cela oui oui tout à
fait en fait et ça c'est une question
éthique
assez assez difficile en fait on a connu
des genres de tri pendant la guerre du
liban qui a qui a traîné une dizaine
quinzaine d'années
et là on s'est dit bon de tout allait
bien jusqu'à ce qu'on ait eue il ya
quelques mois bien quelque chose pour
déjà là cette augmentation en crescendo
des cas et donc on se de nouveau on se
rend compte avec les parties et tickets
les partis qui pensent spécifiquement à
cette question comment trier qu'est-ce
qu'il faut d'ailleurs quelles sont nos
ressources donc à chaque centre
hospitalier à chaque légion ca le soucis
c'est le sou c'est donc le cri devraient
être proportionnelles à ce qu'on a et ça
ça nous pose un problème social éthique
parfois religieux assez important donc
surtout si on prend des ddd des idées de
comme l'âge est ce que c'est éthique de
trier parages de trier par différence et
c'est là donc c'est pas facile du tout
là on est on est on est face à ceux ci
on va faire avec je crois que la
meilleure chose c'est d'augmenter nos
capacités comme vous voulez bien de dire
mais je crois que enfin je crains que
qu'on arrive à un maximum est donc là de
nouveau on cela a mené à faire grimper
un peu plus série probablement d'autant
que le premier ministre démissionnaire
hassan diab n'est pas vraiment rassurant
il dit l'épidémie est hors de contrôle
et le système de santé risque
l'effondrement est ce que c'est le cas
selon vous qui travaillez à l'hôpital
oui mais en fait comme je viens de dire
il n'y a pas eu de d'action préventive
on voyait venir que si pendant les fêtes
les gens vont se l'assemblée vont se
rencontrer jeudi les ensembles vont
faire la fête à la saint sylvestre
c'était un tout petit peuple est bien
prévu tout ça mais bon les autorités
n'ont pas trop vu tout ceci est non
basés ou allemandes les mêmes droits
c'est un témoin
non pas vu où elles n'ont pas voulu voir
je n'entre pas dans ceux des dans ce
débat mais même même la population en
fait même si ici quelqu'un vous dit que
peut très bien vous pouvez faites la
fête bon il fallait un tout petit peu
les zones et les choses et donc se
confiner sans qu on soit obligé ou pas
obligé donc bon mais tout de même on est
là aujourd'hui et je crois que comme
vous dites que vous avez bien dit au
début
là on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix on n'a plus le choix
bien que de l'autre côté on a une crise
économique et sociale très importante
donc je ne sais pas si c'est aussi
important tous pas que le corona mais
pour un cola koffi 19 mais tout de même
sur le premier plat actuellement c'est
la copie 19 bon donc je crois qu'on peut
mettre les choses les autres choses à
côté essayé de faire avec l'aco vide se
confinait essayé de traiter le mieux les
patients et on va voir dans les dix
prochains jours
ma dernière question rapidement s'il
vous plaît quid du vaccin au liban oui
bon comme on était bien entendu le
ministre
il y a quelques mois s'est dit que bon
ils ont déjà fait la commande des
vaccins preiser moderna et probablement
spoutnik le russe et donc on les a pas
encore bon ceci dit comme tout au liban
ça rentre dans un jeu politique au
social au et caetera et donc qui est ce
qui va amener qu'elle serait là le plan
national sur quelles priorités
bon je crois qu'on va attendre ceux ci
dans les prochains jours j'espère très
prochainement pour recevoir ces vaccins
est commencé et qu'on vient de dire
docteur casalino ce n'est pas aux les
amis à l'hémisphère nord seulement à se
vacciner donc ce virus quand il se
circulent librement il fait cesser ces
mutations et donc il peut muter
n'importe où au monde
le passé et le faire des pandémies de
nouvelles pandémies et c'est ce qu'on
craint c'est ce qu'on veut pas merci
jacques joker d'avoir été avec nous dans
vu de l'extérieur pour nous d'avoir
parlé de cette situation inquiétante au
liban également rester avec nous dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la situation des chrétiens dans le monde
selon une ong un chiffre en constante
augmentation
et puis nous parlerons de l'islam en
france d'après un rapport d'human rights
watch le gouvernement français s
immigrés l'islam au terrorisme en cause
la loi sécurité de l'eau balle et le
texte sur le séparatisme
non
[Musique]
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il y à il ya un manque de fiabilité il
ya un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que que la france a été
plus mauvaise que beaucoup de nos pays
étrangers nous sommes le pays qui a
inventé les vaccins avec pasteur dont la
réactivité française n'a pas été à la
hauteur de notre réputation tout le
monde a vu que dès le mois de juillet
les chinois vacciner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a attendu si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
et il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui défendent il n'y a
pas d'alternative au sort du pays
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inutile gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
et vous
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le royaume-uni va-t-il sortir gagnant du
bric site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne mais faisons partie
de l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout les choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir il est
clair que bien qu lieu soit un
partenaire très puissant mieux exporté
bien plus vers le royaume uni comme vous
l'avez dit que le royaume uni vers lieu
il faut bien comprendre que c'est sur la
circulation des biens et sur la
production bien c'est nous qui sommes
perdants c'est les européens
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez de
nouvelles statistiques publiées
aujourd'hui par l'association
protestante évangélique portes ouvertes
le nombre de chrétiens tués pour leur
foi dans le monde a augmenté de 60 % en
2020 passant de 2 1983 à kate 1761 à un
terrible constat qui s'explique en
partie par l'afrique subsaharienne et
plus particulièrement le nigeria où
sévissent les groupes jihadistes autre
indice annuel les églises c'est en chine
qu'elles ont été le plus attaqués
que ce soit par destruction pure et
simple par fermeture administrative ou
par élimination des croix pour en parler
nous sommes avec claude luche maison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir blanche maison
d'après donc les statistiques publiées
on l'a vu par l'association protestante
les chiffres sont très inquiétants ne va
pas les redire une situation contraire
au droit international portant oui bien
sûr c'est cette situation de persécution
et est contraire au droit international
mais leurs internationaux n'est pas
respectée ce don internationale c'est
d'abord la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme des nations unies qui
a été signé à paris précisément en 1948
au palais de chaillot et les 193 états
membres de l'onu doivent respecter et
cette convention qui s'inspire
d'ailleurs de la droite n convention de
la rue lointaine déclaration française
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
en tout cas la liberté de conscience et
la liberté de religion est garanti par
l'onu est ainsi que d'ailleurs le
changement de religion et la conversion
donc et la possibilité de pratiquer sa
religion
alors ceci n'est pas véritablement
respecter par les états parce qu'il ya
des états qui eux mêmes ne respecte pas
d'autres qui laissent faire des groupes
extrémistes ou qui les encourage et puis
d'autres qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'empêcher les dix groupes extrémistes
d'agir
donc pour toutes ces raisons
effectivement les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes et la situation précaire des
chrétiens d'orient et notamment souvent
évoquée depuis les guerres en irak et en
syrie
vous parlez d état que de blanchemaison
justement qu'elle joue t-il quel rôle
pardon joue-t-il fasseur aux pratiques
religieuses
alors tous les états essaient
d'organiser les relations avec les
pratiques religieuses mais de façon
évidemment différente alors le plus
simple c'est la corée du nord puisque
toute pratique religieuse y est
interdite sauf peut-être la vénération
des trois kim mais ça ce n'est pas
vraiment une pratique
jose en chine c'est différent le parti
communiste chinois s'est toujours méfié
les bouddhistes s'est toujours méfié
aussi des chrétiens qu'ils soient
catholiques protestants ou évangélistes
mais il ya quelque temps le pouvoir
le boire de pékin a accepté de négocier
un accord avec le vatican qui permet de
supprimer la distinction entre l'église
officielle de veillance communiste et
réglisse souterraine fidèles au vatican
donc maintenant il ya plus qu une seule
église catholique et le vatican s'est
engagé à consulter les autorités
chinoises avant de nommer deux nouveaux
évêques
ceci fait débat d'ailleurs dans la dans
la dans le monde catholique et aussi
chez les déranger ni ce qui
naturellement ne sont pas n'ont rien à
voir avec cet accord et des églises sont
d'ailleurs toujours fermés ou en voir en
voie de l'être en chine
et puis il ya la situation particulière
de l'arabie saoudite où il n'y a pas de
constitution
mais la religion musulmane est la seule
qui soit à bize
c'est beaucoup c'est en effet un régime
donc musulman république islamiste
autres républiques islamistes l'iran
d'une autre branche de l'islam
si et en iran eh bien on admet qu'il ya
plusieurs religions et l'iran notamment
admet les pratiques religieuses
anciennes comme celles des des chrétiens
d'orient qui sont chaldéens ou qui sont
d'origine
cyriac et qui ne cherchent pas à
convertir les musulmans qui par
conséquent n'exerce aucun prosélytisme
il existe aussi pas beaucoup mais
quelques quelques catholiques en iran et
avec six évêques qui naturellement n'ont
pas donc pas la vie non pas la vie très
facile on peut continuer évidemment à
prendre d'autres exemples comme
exemple pakistan ou état islamique ouh
là là là le blasphème étudie par la loi
et où les gens qui te sens qu'ils sont
qui ne sont pas musulmans éprouvent
beaucoup de difficultés pour les actes
d'état civil pour rentrer dans la
fonction publique au prêt pour diverses
choses par conséquent il ya une
discrimination juridique à l'égard des
chrétiens au pakistan et des
condamnations au titre de cette loi sur
le sur le blasphème en en inde c'est un
peu différent puisque le gouvernement
enfin la constitution dit exactement et
laïque et que toutes les religions sont
sur le même plan en principe mais
évidemment 80% des habitants et en inde
ou de religion hindoue et bien le
gouvernement actuel qui était vraiment
nationaliste veut favoriser les hindous
en organisant l'identité indienne autour
de l'hindouisme ce qui arrive ce qui
revient à discriminer les musulmans et
aussi d'une certaine manière les
chrétiens alors le panorama que vous
faites n'est guère réjouissant comment
expliquer que l'intolérance progressed
ans en 2021 elle progresse parce que les
gouvernements
certains gouvernements en tout cas
utilisent la religion l'instrumentalise
et c'est le cas souvent de gouvernement
nationaliste autoritaire à tendances
autoritaires qui trouve pratique
d'utiliser la religion dominante pour
affirmer leur point de vue mais
également pour peut-être attirer
l'attention sur autre chose que les
difficultés que les békés sociale du
pays il ya aussi évidemment la
concurrence entre divers branche de
l'islam entre les chiites et des
sunnites entre par conséquent l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite
et cette concurrence amen
à accepter des pratiques
discriminatoires qui sont contraires au
droit au droit public international
mais évidemment les pas rester sans
réagir et les opinions publiques
réagissent si l'on prend par exemple
l'exemple du pakistan où une jeune femme
avait été condamnée par un tribunal pour
blasphème
finalement sous la pression de divers
pays d'agde rend notre majorité de pays
occidentaux et bien la cour suprême a
fini par libérer cette jeune femme elle
a malheureusement dû s'exiler elle est
exilée au carré d'art mais est bien
entendu les manifestations réclamant son
exécution continuant le pays ce sont des
groupes extrémistes qui continuent de
manifester contre elle mais les
gouvernements sont pas indifférents à
l'opinion internationale et par
conséquent le rapport qui a été publié
hier aura bien entendu une certaine
influence parce que les gouvernements
n'ont pas envie d'être mis au ban des
nations
ils ont accepté des obligations au titre
des nations unies et doivent les
respecter mais il y aura encore beaucoup
de difficultés sur ce plan et sans doute
des persécutions
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse sur ce
sujet la france dans le viseur de l'om
jeunes human rights watch l'organisation
américaine publie son rapport
aujourd'hui et elle s'inquiète du projet
de loi sécurité globale en france et
précisément son article 24 qui veut
empêcher les prises de vues des forces
de l'ordre lors des manifestations
elle dénonce aussi les amalgames
notamment en assimilant l'islam à la
menace terroriste écoutez nous avons été
profondément préoccupée par la manière
dont le gouvernement français a répondu
à la menace terroriste
oui il y à des actes de violence mais le
gouvernement semble assimiler l'islam en
général à la menace terroriste
et c'est une énorme erreur
la france en dépit de sa tradition de
laïcité doit trouver un moyen de
respecter le droit des gens à croire et
à manifester leur croyance tant qu'il
n'y a pas de violence si le gouvernement
diabolise incroyants quelconque et
assimile la croyance à la violence cela
va éloigner les gens de l'état et poussé
la religion vers la clandestinité
ce qui est finalement très dangereux
alors à ce que la france à 6000 eastham
à la menace terroriste
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec gama la binah cofondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques bonsoir
gamme alabina merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés maxime tu y es beau tu es
docteur en droit bonsoir à vous
également la france qui semble donc
assimiler l'islam en général à la menace
terroriste ont bien de l'entendre de la
bouche du directeur général de la
sérieuse ong human rights watch game
alabina ça vous semble exagéré ou c'est
effectivement ce que vous avez pu
constater ce que vous constatez vous
même
oui dans les fesses on comprend qu'il ya
une une analogie entre 1100 et
terrorisme à cause de certains qui ont
agi violemment et qui se réclament de
l'islam mais en vérité c'est très
exagéré puisque généralise
une accusation à des gens qui n'ont
absolument pas pris parti pour l'immense
majorité à des actions violentes
donc effectivement je comprends la
logique longue à ce qu'on comprenne bien
vous pensez vous que le gouvernement
français puisque c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
il vise ce directeur général de human
rights watch la la loi de séparatisme
vous pensez que la france justement fait
cette assimilation c'est votre avis
également il ya des attentes en
allemagne et en angleterre il ya des
attentes un peu partout et
particulièrement en allemagne angleterre
ce qu'ils sont de pays comparables à la
france
ils n'ont pas ces deux lois nouvelles
qui cible la communauté musulmane ont
fait des justes appliquer les lois de
sécurité qui s'appliquent dans tous les
pays démocratiques à destination de ceux
qui ont commis des actes de violence
en france il aurait fallu faire des lois
pour cible est effectivement façon très
claire même si le disent pas façon
explicite ce qu'ils appellent la
communauté musulmane donc les gens qui
seraient donc pratique musulmane qui
serait vu comme musulman effectivement
maxime thibeault vous portez le même
regard la france fait des raccourcis
bon je trouve que la france fait pas
spécialement des raccourcis moi je veux
pas tomber dans ce faux débat quant à
savoir si on a un amalgame entre les
musulmans et l'islam isme on sait très
bien qu'à nombreux musulmans qui veulent
vivre leur religion
normalement en france qui ne supportent
pas l'islamisme et qui ne supporte pas
en réalité l'absence d'intervention
d'état pour mettre fin à un islamisme
radical et c'est ça le vrai problème
aujourd'hui
moi je pense que en réalité la loi ne
devrait pas s'appeler séparatisme elle
devrait s'appeler naissance de la
république parce que ce qu'on est en
train de vivre aujourd'hui c'est
l'absence complète de la république et
c'est parce que la république c'était
face et que des groupuscules l'islamisme
radical tout un tas de groupuscules
viennent remplacer sur plan des valeurs
l'absence de république française est
donc en fait que cette loi à mon sens on
pourra en parler mais si vous voulez on
ne fait pas en fait la république à être
du droit on décrète pas la république
ont la vie et c'est un peu ce que je
regrette et je voudrais pas qu'on tombe
en même temps dans un fou discours à
dire que la france amalgame islam et
islamisme on sait pertinemment qu'il ya
une distinction
on sait malheureusement que des gens
passent de l'islam à l'islamisme qu'il
ya un lien naturel parce que le texte
est le même c'est à dire que
l'interprétation du coran n'est pas la
même mais on reste sur ce même texte
il s'est quand même créé on ne peut pas
passer à côté mais je ne voudrais pas
convenable est ce le problème
aujourd'hui de l'intégration ou bien
tout simplement de la lutte contre
l'islamisme a simplement fois amalgame
avec l'islam
gama labinal ong du juge clairement
notre laïcité trop durs notamment
évidemment vers l'islam c'est de ça
qu'il s'agit ça veut dire qu'on serait
moins tolérants avec une religion
qu'avec une autre en france est votre
avis également bien évidemment qui est
la tolérance mais je vais répondre à ce
qu il m a dit d'abord c'est pas une loi
sur le sur la le séparatisme puisqu'on
utilise depuis 7h mais retoqué la loi
puisque conseil constitue elle s'y était
opposée évidemment et à juste titre non
c'est une loi qui effectivement cible
en conséquence le conseil des excuses
mon nom c'est très juste cause et à ce
bout
donc qui a retoqué pourquoi pas ce qu'il
dit qu'effectivement le caractère
stigmatisant la j'aime pas le cas parce
qu'il est très chrétien les stigmates
c'est jésus bref ces caractères qui
cible de façon claire les musulmans au
sens large dit quoi et dit que si
quelqu'un parce qu'il ya toujours le jir
et le délit d'intention maintenant les
dents le délit d'intention n'est plus
dans l'action dans la volonté d'agir
mais dans la tension et ça commence à
poser pour l'ania plusieurs textes dans
ce projet de loi mais en substance ce
qui se passe c'est que quand on dit par
exemple que il ya des volontés
séparatistes d'une population gens lui
dire simplement que d'abord la
séparation c'est un principe républicain
on essaie par l église et d'état ensuite
on a séparé paris à la banlieue
ensuite on a séparé paris et la province
bref la séparation les structures elle
elle est sociale elle est historique
évidemment puisqu'on a séparé l'histoire
de france 2 sont cogné à l'isthme et
tout cela ça crée des tensions et en
vérité pour faire très simple j'ai envie
de dire que le problème problématiques
qui se posent aujourd'hui à nous c'est
de ses devoirs que rompois du doigt une
communauté dans son ensemble et on
accélère un dégradation de la relation
du de ce qu'on appelait vivre ensemble
en créant ce genre de pointage c'est que
les gens même si inconsciemment ils
disent que c'est pas pour nous
évidemment on n'est pas des terroristes
ou quoi que ce soit mais c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'ils aient une action
violente
immédiatement on dit les musulmans ont
dit pas seulement maintenant c'est plus
en plus évident donc plus seulement
islamisme et les musulmans ensuite
concernant la lecture du coran non il ya
un coran c'est vrai mais il ya quatre
écoles juridiques et des différents
courants de pensée radicaux dont
certains qui sont amies de la frange
départ de larbi dit saoudite
effectivement ça pose moins de problème
parce que l argent tu donc pour tout
vous dire en substance j'ai commencé un
scandale ça je suis d'accord avec ce
livre est en rupture de relations
diplomatiques parce que c'est quand même
qui a généré tout ce qui est juste et
l'arriération la culture musulmane
mais encore une fois quand on dit qu'il
ya une volonté de séparation la volonté
de séparation elle est de fait l'abandon
des quartiers sa clique arty ne voulait
pas être séparés mais j'en ai de vous
dire par rapport au ton peu proposée aux
écoles par exemple de plus faire l'école
à la maison mais l'école de la
république qui sont des écoles poubelle
en banlieue et je le dis malgré le fait
que les profs se bat ce sont des écoles
poubelle sans moyens quand vous y allez
vous allez dans une garderie gérante de
délinquance parce que on a tout fait
pour les écarter
ça c'est un vrai problème de séparation
qui va faire régler mexique est bon que
pense le docteur en droit justement que
vous êtes vous qui avez certainement lu
ce projet de loi séparatisme
ça y'est domérat de tout on trouve par
exemple l'article 18 qui va être la
reprise de l'article 24 sur la loi
sécurité globale et y aller porter
atteinte à la liberté de la presse et la
liberté d'expression donc un mois ce
texte qui me gêne pour une raison simple
c'est que la république se décrète pas
et là où je vous rejoins alors on n'est
pas d'accord sur le constat mais non je
vous rejoins c'est qu'en fait il ya plus
de république française c'est pas
séparatisme le vrai nom c'est c'est ya
plus de république c'est à dire qu'on
intègre plus c'est à dire qu'on ne met
plus la méritocratie en place c'est à
dire que là où dans les banlieues on
devrait agir pour replacer la république
on ne fait rien moi par exemple je suis
pour qu'on pour la mixité au sein de
l'école c'est à dire qu'il ya des quotas
qu'on puisse pas simplement mettre les
enfants dans leurs banlieues dans des
écoles poubelles qui les enfants de vos
cartes id dans des écoles de beaux
quartiers mais qui est une obligation de
mixité se le font certains pays ce que
ne fait pas la france moi je suis pour
l'établissement du service national
parce que je le dis je le répète en
permanence quand vous mettez le petit
mohamed de banlieue avec le petit kevin
de zones rurales ensemble pendant trois
mois et dont je peux vous dire que la
république qu'ils apprennent à la vivre
à steve la cohésion ils vivent là ils
vivent la difficulté ensemble et il
n'est comme ça ça permet de faire mettre
en fait des valeurs communes et le
problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne fait
plus de mixité républicaine la
république en fait et la laïcité on en
parlait tout à l'heure sont devenus des
choses complètement terme sont devenus
des éléments inexistant des éléments
purement juridique et on a pu me de
chaleur il ya plus de spiritualité
derrière notre nation c'est à dire qu'on
rassemble plus les gens derrière quelque
chose qui devrait les dépasser et ça
c'est un problème qui est plus globale
en réalité c'est à dire que les 900
total de sacralisation en tout c'est à
dire que plus rien ne nous dépasse
normalement la présidence de la
république devrait avoir une place au
dessus de tous elle devrait être un
vecteur de réconciliation nationale et
en fait on voit que président de la
république se rabaisse aux plus basses
polémiques et j'ai plein d'exemples
comme ça donc en fait ça prenne beaucoup
plus globale et cette simple loi ne va
rien changer
la serait intéressant que du bon il ya d
une partie sur laquelle vous rejoindre
qui morte c'est le travail provoquaient
la mixité
parce qu'aujourd'hui les commissions
l'attribution des hlm tout comme les
établissements poubelle
toujours été fait on a fait en sorte de
mettre à la tipp à la périphérie de la
capitale ce qui gênait ceux qui étaient
trop colorée ça rappelle un peu le le
général le maréchal leclerc qui arrive
en france
libérant la capitale il met ses noix à
ces arbres derrière pour ne pas libérer
une capitale pas ce qu'il a dit on ne
peut pas montrer aux parisiens qui l'ont
libéré par leur part l'or l'or alors
colonie clairement la couleur pose
problème et effectivement il ya une
responsabilité d'état qui est très
lourde et même d'ailleurs macro l'avait
rappelé dans son discours il a dit
qu'effectivement il faut regarder les
choses en face on a abandonné circule
ces territoires ce qui me surprend
d'ailleurs chez vous c'est que vous
étiez un gilet jaune donc le discours
que vous tenez l'état mais secours
auquel je peux adhérer facilement j'ai
quand même temps vous avez été aussi
bien écrit sur les gilet jaune monsieur
c'est pas la même griffe vous aviez non
vous aviez sympathie pour eux quand je
dis vous et lg jour s'entend mais à tout
le monde et gilet jaune en absolu pâtit
pour les mouvements poker la kabbale à
mi chemin pour arriver là de ce point de
vue là if plus produits de la liste qui
est intéressant mais après arriver sur
réponse qui est au national cbt
attention nationale c'est surprenant je
trouve ça très nettement d'un pare
balles jeunes surtout parce que vous
avez la chance de quand même de
connaître un peu là-bas j'espère un pour
vous et vous rendez bien compte que la
rupture française et turcs eurent
d'abord sociale ethnique et c'était
planifié ce n'est pas un hasard quand on
l'a fait des aides que les écoles
poubelles cédric lechat parce que j'en
ai connu logique racialiste je suis pas
du tout moi je vais pas durant
simplement pas des réponses figuration
qui n'ont pas su être qu'ils n'ont pas
être intégrée qui n'ont pas été
assimilée et ça c'est un vrai problème
c'est à dire que autant avec les vagues
d'immigration de portugais ou d'italien
qu'on a connus on a eu moins de
problèmes d'assimilation parce qu'on
avait une culture identique avec les
vagues qu'on a connus norma grève ça pas
du tout à fait la même chose parce que
c'est des religions différentes et là où
je pense que les années 70 sont est un
véritable échec c'est qu'on aurait dû
soudé ces gens là autour d'une culture
commune autour de valeurs communes ne
pas les pactes et dans des banlieues et
malheureusement c'est ce qui a été fait
donc je trouve ça
dynacor est ce que vous dites là non
mais ça je suis certain qu'on sera pas
d'accord mais moi je pense avec une cage
en bois où nos arabe et je trouve ça ça
commence à me fatiguer c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a un point on crée des
m'appelle non mais aujourd'hui on met un
point on crée des labels de diversité
moi je connais pas de diversité en
france
je ne connais que la communauté
nationale je ne connais que la
communauté nationale
non c'est bon mais dix années
c'est pas fini je recherche ma musique
c'est la gamme à l'habitat l'émission
c'est lenoir
c'est pas un problème madoff coates
était d'abord et puis quelques couleurs
mais c'est moi qu'a réussi l'un des plus
beaux concours de l'état par son mérite
et pas par sa couleur et j'en ai marre
qu'on réalise les gens leurs couleurs au
lieu de les rayonnages à la migraine
cela s'appelle une cela s'appelle une
exception on peut réussir mais c'est pas
nous arrêter là général chez monsieur on
a laissé à l'université mais écoutez moi
mon ex femme affiche 1 écoutez moi mon
ex femme a fait suite de quoi elle était
la seule d'accord des quartiers
populaires je parle des pauvres en
général c'est soit des six ambassadeurs
des gens riches niveau mais maintenant
pour vos bons dirigeants de l'opérateur
ruraux et ça va finir mon propos laisse
moi connaissions pas problème
c'est sûr ils sont ils sont marqués les
ya encore pire mais bon on en écoute on
vous dit que vous dites oui oui mais si
vous mais c'est par là on est arrivé
vous êtes dans une posture il est quand
même intéressant si vous écoutez donc
vous dites que vous n'êtes pas pour le
racialisme c'est un fait établi
politique quand contre le général
leclerc arrive en france
il aimait son immigration dr c'est
l'histoire qui parlent ensuite
l'histoire parle encore quand les
polonais arrivaient en france est le but
du siècle dernier on est parqué dans le
nord de la france parce qu'on dit qu'il
des porteurs de maladies pourtant les
polissons catholique en les pubs les
français quand les italiens arrivent
c'est des blousons noirs ils se font
massacrer dans les années va pas ce qui
est effectivement un arrêt un député qui
est assassiné signes ne trompent pas il
ya une centaine de morts cercle assez
pour que là on a pu les assimiler comme
vous dites termes très violents parce
que les simulations ça ne produit pas de
belles choses en général mais on a pu
les assimiler parce qu'elle est pas
encore de crise économique majeure quand
les magrets baril en france à la suite
d'une guerre d'une défaite
la dernière défaite française dans une
guerre l'extérieur qu'est ce qui se
passe on arrive dans 79 des gradins
économique conséquence de quoi vous
conjuguez dégradation conséquences
économiques augmentation effectivement
avec le regroupement familial de la
présence maghrébine en france et
marginalisation dignité soumis sous
mitterrand tsimi terrain karim c'est ça
et bien là et dacquois à des tensions
qui se multiplient vous rajoutez à cela
les tensions internationales politiques
dans lesquels la france intervient liban
irak syrie mali lydie tous et tous ces
éléments constituent dans l'inconscient
collectif des jeunes maghrébins le
sentiment qu à la fois ils sont parqués
comme des bestiaux dans les banlieues
mais qu'en plus leurs pays d'origine ont
droit à un traitement de faveur
militaire de bombardements c'est cela la
vraie problématique en italie là des
fleurs
la réponse est le mot de la fin pour
vous maxime qui est bon non c'était
terrible aussi c'est qu'on a fait croire
aux gamins de banlieue qui pourraient
tous est dit nadine dheedene alors que
la réalité c'est y vivait le chômage de
masse et donc malheureusement but l'état
abandonné on a eu l'augmentation aussi
l'intégration de l'islam radical
j'ai a su capter cette jeunesse en
déshérence et l'emmener vers un verre
des verts au final une commande par
l'islam radical et sas énormément gênant
et rien n'a été fait dans ce sens là et
donc moi ça me dérange énormément parce
que c'est là où il faudrait agir en
réalité pour restaurer la république
dans nos banlieues
mais la république aussi elle doit être
intransigeante elle ne l'est pas je
pense et je le constate en fait avec
l'islam radical où elle ne lui pas
suffisamment où elle n'applique pas
suffisamment la loi merci en tout cas
tous les deuxièmes alabina maxime
thibeault d'avoir accepté ce débat sur
rt france dont le reste de l'actualité
on en revient dans ces manifestations
aujourd'hui en belgique
les centaines de manifestants se sont
affrontés avec la police devant un
commissariat à bruxelles où un homme
noir a été arrêtée trouvé la mort samedi
ils ont réclamé que la lumière soit
faite sur les circonstances de ce décès
l'homme a été arrêté après avoir tenté
de fuir des policiers qui contrôlaient
un groupe de personnes réunies malgré
l'interdiction de rassemblement il avait
commencé à filmer la scène avant que les
policiers l'interpellent ibrahim ans et
comme mon frère pour moi c'est comme si
j'étais de la famille et donc j'ai le
droit demande signé parce que c'est la
mort
d'un être humain et nous estimons que
c'est tout à fait normal que les gens
sont dignes ici on est d'abord un deuil
c'est la raison principale pour laquelle
nous sommes tous là la deuxième raison
c'est réclamer justice et justice soit
faite et on veut simplement la vérité en
fait parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont flous concernant là c'est
concernant les circonstances de la mort
de brahim alexeï navalni en route vers
la russie en convalescence en allemagne
après avoir été victime d'un
empoisonnement présumé en août
l'homme politique russe annonce
aujourd'hui son intention de rentrer
dans son pays dimanche en dépit d'une
menace d'une peine de prison
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
clairon c'est sur son compte instagram
cas l'excès navalni a annoncé dans une
vidéo
son retour en russie un retour planifié
pour ce dimanche 17 janvier via une
compagnie aérienne russe low cost qui
dessert l'allemagne
l'opposant qui prétend que vladimir
poutine a personnellement commandité son
assassinat estime que les autorités font
tout ce qu'elles peuvent pour empêcher
qu'il revienne en russie et c'est
notamment une peine de prison ferme qui
pourrait l'attendre à son retour à
moscou en effet alexeï navalni a été
condamné à trois ans et demi de prison
avec sursis en 2014 pour détournement de
fonds et dans le cadre de cette affaire
la période probatoire à laquelle il
était soumis avait été prolongé jusqu'à
la fin de l'année 2020 ils s'exposent
donc théoriquement à une peine de prison
ferme s'il est jugé qu' alexeï navalni
n'a pas respecté les conditions de son
sursis en ne retournant pas
immédiatement en russie après sa
convalescence passé en allemagne
attendons maintenant dimanche tout
d'abord pour voir si l'opposant
effectuera bien le voyage prévu et le
cas échéant observer la réaction des
autorités à son retour sur le sol russe
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes pour 1 point complexe
sur l'actualité
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir on ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature
ça reste un art des coques maintenant
c'est l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques setting godard qui disait
cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité
[Musique]